♪ ♪ ♪
- Depuis la fermeture des mines
d'amiante, la région de Thetford
Mines a diversifié son économie
de façon spectaculaire.
Résultat : la région manque
cruellement de main-d'oeuvre.
- Il y a de l'emploi ici,
il y a beaucoup d'emploi.
On embauche beaucoup ici.
- Nous avions rencontré Ismaïla
et sa famille en 2018.
Quatre ans après son arrivée
au Québec, il travaillait encore
comme ouvrier dans une usine,
alors qu'il a un baccalauréat
en gestion et une vaste
expérience.
ISMAÏLA KANTÉ
- On accepte de travailler
sur le plancher pour avoir
l'expérience québécoise.
Une fois qu'on a l'expérience,
donnez-nous la chance,
l'opportunité d'exploiter
nos diplômes, nos expériences
de vie.
- Quatre ans plus tard,
la famille Kanté s'est
agrandie...
-Venez manger!
- ...et s'est habituée aux
questions sur ses origines.
KODI KANTÉ
- Ils viennent, genre : "Wow!
Salut! Comment ça va? Tu viens
d'où?" Vu que je suis Noir,
genre. Parce que... Et là,
ils s'intéressent.
- Ça fait que, toi, ce que
t'aimes le mieux du Québec,
c'est les Québécois?
- Ouais, c'est ça.
Et la nourriture!
- Et la nourriture?
Qu'est-ce que t'aimes?
- La poutine.
- Haby a été au front de
la COVID dans un CHSLD, tout en
suivant une formation pour être
reconnue comme infirmière
auxiliaire.
HABY KANTÉ
- Je travaille avec des
collègues qui sont infirmières,
médecins, puis... c'est ça.
Au pays, en Afrique. Mais ici,
c'est ça, il faut commencer
par...
- Être préposée?
- Préposée.
- On a beaucoup plus de chance
d'avoir quelque chose avec
un certificat d'ici qu'une
maîtrise de l'extérieur.
- C'est Éva Lopez qui nous avait
présenté à la famille Kanté.
Arrivée de la Colombie
il y a 30 ans, elle a fondé
un organisme qui aide à
l'intégration des immigrants.
Elle voulait faire cette
entrevue dans la halte garderie
parce que le manque de places
en services de garde freine
l'intégration, des femmes
en particulier.
EVA LOPEZ, DG, Intégration
communautaire des immigrants
- Les gens qui veulent se
franciser, qui veulent suivre
une formation pour mieux
s'organiser, ils peuvent pas,
parce qu'il n'y a pas de place
en garderie.
- L'intervenante souligne aussi
le manque de classes d'accueil
en région.
- Alors, les enfants, ils sont
étiquetés comme des enfants qui
ont des retards d'apprentissage,
parce qu'ils ne parlent pas
la langue! Ça, c'est grave!
C'est grave parce qu'on est en
train d'envoyer une génération
d'enfants vers un cul-de-sac.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Comme ailleurs au Québec,
le prix des maison a explosé
dans la région.
Le coût des loyers aussi.
RACHID KHOUDANE,
employé, Boulangerie St-Méthode
- Ici, il n'y a pas de logement
à louer ici. C'est rare, ici.
- Oui, c'est très cher.
1100 dollars par mois.
- 1100 dollars! Aïe aïe aïe!
Rachid et Yousri ont été
recrutés par la Boulangerie
St-Méthode, au Maroc et
en Tunisie. Ils sont heureux
au travail, mais l'éloignement
de la famille est difficile.
YOUSRI ZANZOURI,
employé, Boulangerie St-Méthode
- Il y a un peu de difficulté,
parce que je quitte...
ma petite fille me manque
beaucoup. C'est ça.
- Quand Rachid a quitté
le Maroc, il y a trois ans,
sa fille n'avait que 7 mois.
Il ne l'a pas revue depuis.
- J'ai trouvé ça dur. Pour moi,
c'est très très dur. Parfois...
ma patience est partie.
BENOIT FAUCHER, président,
Boulangerie St-Méthode
- Ce qu'on demande, c'est
de tout simplement accélérer
les processus.
On utilise aussi beaucoup
d'avoine dans nos pains.
- Benoit Faucher embauche
une quinzaine de travailleurs
étrangers et en attend
une vingtaine d'autres. Il sait
que pour garder ses employés,
ils doivent faire venir
leurs familles, même s'il manque
de logements abordables
et de places en garderie.
- Il y a peut-être pas tout
ce qu'il faut, mais s'il manque
de travailleurs, qui va
travailler dans nos restaurants?
Qui va faire le pain, d'abord?
- Mais accepter des dizaines
de milliers de travailleurs
temporaires additionnels
serait contre-productif,
selon Éva Lopez.
- Ça se serait un suicide social
parce qu'on n'a pas la capacité.
Il faudrait que demain matin,
on décide qu'il y a un budget
extra, sublime, immense pour
pouvoir bâtir des logements,
mais c'est demain matin!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Hé!
- Salut!
- Bon matin, Ismaïla! En forme?
- Ça va bien?
- Oui, oui.
- Après avoir fait un certificat
à l'Université du Québec
et passé des dizaines
d'entrevues d'embauche, Ismaïla
a enfin obtenu un poste à
la Caisse populaire de Thetford
Mines. Il est conseiller
en finances personnelles.
ISABELLE MAHEUX, Caisse de la
région de Thetford, Desjardins
- En début de mandat, donc
lorsqu'il a eu sa clientèle,
effectivement, on a reçu
des appels de certaines
personnes qui désiraient
changer de conseiller, et vous
comprendrez que, on a tolérance
zéro, on n'accepte pas
un changement de conseiller...
pour laisser place au racisme
ou à la différence qui dérange,
en fait.
- Souvent, pendant les périodes
d'élections, on essaie de tirer
sur la carte, comme si tous
les problèmes du monde venaient
des immigrants. Il y en a
certains. Mais j'ai trouvé
quand même que la majorité ici
sont ouverts à l'immigration,
sont ouverts au monde, et puis
les gens sont très accueillants.
- Ismaïla a cogné aux portes
pendant six ans avant de trouver
un emploi à la mesure de ses
compétences. Mais il n'a jamais
regretté d'avoir choisi le
Québec pour élever sa famille.